wir wollen wissen wer sind die sechs
glücklichen die eins der begehrten cdu
schrott ministerien bekommen
ich kann es nicht erwarten dass große
heute-show minister bingo oliver welke
weiß heute schon bis morgen wird oder
auch nicht
ach das ist ganz einfach wirklich das
macht sich im grunde von alleine
minister bingo wirtschaftsminister ich
nehme die spannung raus wird natürlich
peter altmaier ja weil er ist einfach
verdient hat und weil er sich auskennt
mit hohen ämtern und jetzt bin ich hier
in oldenburg grünkohlkönig und das freut
mich und das ist der höhepunkt meiner
politischen karriere
ja mal ohne witz ein oldenburger
grünkohlkönig hat mehr zu sagen als der
deutsche wirtschaftsminister so und
werdet willenlose büttel des
bauernverbands also
landwirtschaftsminister eine gelernte
weinkönigin ja wer denn sonst sehr
ländlich geprägt konnte erst traktor
fahren bevor ich hier den führerschein
gemacht habe ich hatte eine lieblings
ziege oder schwarz und ist susi ja
dummerweise hat sie dann später die susi
mit dem traktor überfahren aber das ist
eine andere geschichte
ebenfalls gehandelt für irgendwas wird
die weitgehend unbekannte annette
widmann mauz bekommt wahrscheinlich dass
katzen ministerium
und ist natürlich zuständig für die
ausländer maut angeblich heißt es
angeblich muss noch einen ossie dabei
sein aber da kannst du ja im prinzip
irgendein nehmen
lippi zum beispiel wegen der quote halt
wir haben noch ossi quote bei der cdu
und dann brauchst du aus proporz gründen
natürlich noch ein alibi merkel gegner
weil sie so ein herz konservativen
hardliner am besten mit trachtenjanker
die zeichen sind so bürger nicht wie
lange nicht
es gibt ein wahnsinniges bedürfen ist in
der heimat geborgenheit kulturellen
sicherheit übersichtlichkeit ja mehr
kulturelle übersichtlichkeit das wäre
schön
die akademische art zu sagen es gibt
hier echt zu viele ausländer bisschen
afd werden um die afg zu schwächen
dieses sparen methode hat noch nie
funktioniert aber egal
mein tipp merkel macht den jens zum
gesundheitsminister warum weil sie ihn
wirklich hast ja
gesundheitsminister das ist die mutter
aller art karten und flinten uschi sind
wir uns eigentlich bleibt natürlich im
amt natürlich wenn man auch wenn es da
aus unionskreisen ausgerechnet heute
anders lautender gerüchte gab die uschi
muss bleiben